schon in drei jahren soll ein sehr
ungewöhnliches gefährt auf dem mars zum
einsatz kommen die nasa hat speziell für
den roten planeten einen hubschrauber
entwickelt und schon den drei jahren
solle auf dem mars starten dafür muss er
allerdings vollkommen neu konstruiert
werden denn auf der erde flugfähige
helikopter würden auf den mars nicht
einmal abheben mir das ganze trotzdem
funktioniert und wo die risiken liegen
dass jetzt den blick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
satelliten können sich der mars
oberfläche nur auf eine entfernung von
einigen kilometer nähern
und das ist schon sehr nah trotzdem
müssen sie schnell fliegen und brauchen
sehr hochauflösende instrumente um die
oberfläche zu untersuchen deshalb plant
die nasa jetzt ein einmaliges experiment
denn ein experiment ist es denn noch nie
wurde in der raumfahrt ähnliches
versucht mit der mars mission mars two
thousand and i wird es jetzt einmalig
einen helikopter auf dem mars geben
dabei sind die technischen
voraussetzungen erheblich denn hier auf
der erde liegt der höhenrekord für
hubschrauber bei rund 13 kilometern
da die luft auf dem mars aber so dünn
ist gleich in die bedingungen auf der
mars oberfläche also ganz unten schon
den hier auf der erde in einer höhe von
rund 30 kilometern
der hubschrauber muss also gänzlich
anders konstruiert werden so drehen sich
die rotorblätter mit 3000 umdrehungen in
der minute zehn mal schneller als auf
der erde und das gewicht des fluggerätes
darf nicht hoch seien 1,8 kilo wiegt die
köpfe unter den rotorblättern und muss
dabei einiges an technologie
transportieren die kapsel ist in etwa so
groß wie ein fußball und muss zusätzlich
zum motor weiteren technik enthalten um
einsatzbereit so bleiben so muss die
technik zb in den mars nächten beheizt
werden weil die kälte ansonsten sie
beschädigen würde zudem braucht der
helikopter elektronik für einen
autopiloten da die entfernung zum mars
zu groß ist um das fluggerät in echtzeit
zu steuern
ein signal würde mehrere licht minuten
benötigen um dort anzukommen das projekt
wird von der nasa als ein hochrisiko
projekt gesehen
zu viele unwägbarkeiten könnten dieses
experimentelle fluggerät zum scheitern
bringen allerdings wäre es der hammer
wenn es klappen würde einfach mal über
den nächsten hügel gucken was da ist das
war bisher noch nicht möglich aber
wenn's klappt dann werden die jetzt hier
natürlich zuerst erfahren wenn ihr zu
den ersten gehören wollte ihn dabei sind
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch
auch mit kilogramm instagram oder dem
facebook manager mit wir verknüpfen
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten videothek nicht
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von pink somit
machen und zum beispiel themen
vorschlagen
einfach hier drauflegen und zur
begrüßung habe ich ein kleines goodie
und natürlich nicht das abo mit
der genau der glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sensationsfund auf dem mars ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran